[Musique]
c'est une nuit une nouvelle génération
va naître et pour cela nous avons créé
une école spécialement beau jésus à lisa
ravi de connaître
[Musique]
soyez très attentifs ça peut vous sauver
la vie tu devras enseigner notre voir
[Musique]
les euros la possibilité de partager
leur pouvoir de devenir plus fort que
jamais notre médicaux il arrive des
choses tristes
c'est toi qui dans mes pensées usa mais
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
s'il te plaît ne faites pas ça c'est pas
toi on devient de plus en plus forte
elle est différente elle est peut-être
du musée possible m'aurait dit dracula
était sur le bateau avec tournée on
était en quelque sorte rac you lie morts
crois moi tout ce qui est plus vivre
nous avons à pleurs pour qui elle se
prostitue d'enfants nous avons vaincu
dracula vous pouvez vous retirer
il faut qu'on se tienne prêt nous allons
l'étudier comme si nos vies en
dépendaient
parce que c'est une carte mur n'est que
des enfants ne sommes pas que deux
enfants
il se passe est grave
[Musique]